it's time for hatred mail quick reminder
this is what hatred mail is it's like a
mandatory transvaginal ultrasound for
your mind Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom
all right the theme of this week's
hatred mail a common theme among many
hatreds
confusion around the First Amendment and
free speech and censorship take a listen
David Pakman you have succeeded in cut
and paste journalism as to so spread
lies and fabrications to the people who
somehow think you are smart
lies and defamations are not free speech
defamation is where there is a price to
pay for what comes out the mouth it is
not free and you are in commerce to
carry out lies to support your business
there isn't an ounce of truth to you are
saying about the president and really
you should be sued or have liens on you
for defaming and conspiracy your
statements are your opinion or are you a
practicing psychology careful what you
do there are people who will do so trump
is busy being president whose IQ is far
above yours and experience much more
vast your show will not last because
haters are not people who prosper and
are affluent your time is coming soon to
own up to your lies I could not possibly
say it better myself so I won't and that
is really a stinging indictment of the
liens that should be put against me by
the way how do you put a lien against a
person that means that it in order to
put a lien against a person wouldn't
people be able to have to be property
like a slave okay
I don't know cuz usually you put like a
lien against someone's house or there's
like a mechanic's lien if you don't pay
for car repairs or something like that
but how to put a lien against something
it that that something has to be
property and I am no one's property Pat
that I can say for sure
no you're certainly not and how could
anyone argue that Trump has a superior
IQ to you or anyone else really it's
tough to make that case it really is but
what you can do and now
I will make this case you can turn
hatred mail into something good for the
show by employing the coupon code hey
tree at 40 that will save you 40% off of
your membership at david pakman.com
slash membership that's kind of like how
you give a nephew middle finger salute
to the hey tree it's by saying your
message has encouraged me to become a
david pakman show member it's a
beautiful thing the patriotic thing to
do is absolutely that's true progressive
patriotism